Pass duour vous allez voir c'est encore
une histoire alors complètement dingue
on rigole là mais vous allez voir encore
on va dire qu'on marche sur la tête
Véronique c'est une femme de 71 ans elle
est malade d'un cancer depuis 5 ans elle
sort tout juste de chimiothérapie elle
est victime de squat de squat par son
locataire dans sa maison en Dordogne
elle est donc obligée de dormir dans une
tente dans une tente dans son propre
jardin c'estàdire elle peut pas aller
chez elle parce qu'il y a le gars qui
squat et la loi malheureusement ne peut
rien faire pour elle c'est un truc de
fou vous allez voir elle est avec nous
dans un instant
je vous dis quand on vous dit qu'on
marche sur la tête ça ça va vous rendre
fou là chez vous 20h23 vous allez voir
on se dit pas je sais pas où on est
qu'on comprend pas regardez l'istoire
Véronique depuis une semaine on est
entré dans la phase de la trêve
hivernale une période pendant laquelle
les squatterurs ne peuvent pas être
délogés je viens de d'aller à
l'appartement et il y a 7 ou h personnes
à l'intérieur et il m'ont mis dehors
mais en d'ordogne une sexagénère
atteinte d'un cancer lutte depuis déjà
plusieurs mois face à son locataire qui
refuse de payer le loyer et de partir il
m'a dit je reste on ne déménage pas
aujourd'hui dans l'impasse la femme de
61 ans est même obligé de camper dans le
jardin ce n'est pas à moi de dormir
dehors c'est ma maison je l'ai payé
Véronique atteinte d'un cancer dort dans
une tente au fond de son jardin car sa
maison est squatté elle témoigne ce soir
dans
TPMP merci d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup véroniqueci Merci à VOUS
Véronique c'estes tellement mignonne
franchement c'est vra quand je l'ai vu
arriver l'histoire de Véronique elle va
nous va nous bouleverser euh vous avez
acheté une maison il y a combien de
temps en 2000 2000 donc quand même pas
mal de temps oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui vous l' pourquoi vous l'avez mise en
location à la base bah je l'ai mise en
location parce que j'ai dû c'est une
maison en fait qui a été séparée donc
j'ai acheté une première partie en 2000
et j'ai acheté la deuxième partie qui
est l'accès à la rue parce que c'est il
y avait une servitude je passais dans
les caves pour accéder à la rue donc
j'ai acheté cette deuxième partie de
maison
en en 2000 c'est ça en 2000 donc j'ai dû
la banque avec la la maladie ne m'a pas
donner ce que je voulais non plus donc
j'ai j'ai j'ai loué ma propre maison
pour pouvoir donner vie à l'autre maison
alors justement euh pourquoi vous avez
voulu la la récupérer en fait parce que
bah parce que j'ai pris la décision
parce que parce que ma mère ne peut plus
rester en en résidence autonomie
d'accord donc j'ai je je je j'ai voulu
la récupérer pour pour moi et pour pour
ma mère alors vous aviez des problèmes
avec les locataires avant avant cette
histoire ou pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout des des des problèmes des
problèmes de de de enfin des des des des
des trucs qui me gênaient des petites
choses qui me gênaient le leur mode de
vie ce sont ce sont des jeunes ce sont
des jeunes qui ont décidé de ne pas
travailler donc automatiquement ils
n'ont pas la même vie que nous on
scembre dernier donc quand vous avez
expliqué au locataire que vous vouliez
récupérer l' l'appartement ils vous ont
dit quoi ah mais on peut pas c'estd on
peut pas on on a rien trouvé on peut pas
donc ils ont au début ils ont accepté le
le préavis de 6 mois non ils ont ah au
début mais bien sûr et en plus en plus
il m'a il m'a dit quand il a signé il
m'a dit euh oui vous m'en aviez parlé
oui oui je comprends vous m'en aviez
parlé donc oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que
j'avais je lui enais tout touché de mots
à oui oui oui
et et quand vous êtes revenu 6 mois plus
tard et comme je suis pas 6 mois pas 6
mois 5 mois et quelques et quelques
jours parce que j'ai voulu j'ai je l'ai
appelé pour faire un pré état des lieux
sortant et puis et puis bah là il me dit
mais non non non non non non on n'est
pas prêt nous on a rien trouvé on part
pas alors donc il part pas et vous vous
faites quoi là et ben là je lui dis mais
attends attends attends attends on on
s'est mal compris là moi je fais quoi là
c'est quoi je j'ai j'ai j'ai plus de
maison j'ai plus de toi j'ai je te rou
et là il m' a dit c'est votre problème
comment ça c'est votre problème c'est
mon problème donc là euh qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites à ce moment-là
bah à ce moment-là je euh je me dis
c'est c'est j'y crois pas j'y crois pas
je me dis c'est pas possible en fait il
y a 6 mois il a signé euh
et et je contacte la dille chez nous
enfin chez en France ça doit être la Nil
non nous c'est c'est la Nil la dille
enfin bon je prends rendez-vous qui me
disent que par le fait euh la lettre est
très correcte et puis et mais son
assistante sociale m'appelle une semaine
après donc en fait on était vraiment 15
jours là à ce moment-là on était
vraiment 15 jours avant le déménagement
alors euh vous pourquoi vous avez décidé
de dormir dans dans dans une tente dans
le
jardin bah parce que euh parce que ma ma
fille ma fille mes enfants euh
m'ont m'ont m'ont bien sûr m'ont
accueilli c'est normal c'est normal mais
euh mais en même temps je j'ai appris
qu'il squatit le jardin aussi en mon
absence c'était facile pour eux de euh
de de bah de de squatter tout mais et la
deuxième maison c'est ça que je comprend
pas là en fait alors bah la deuxième
maison en fait elle est bah elle était
pas praticable pour ma mère c'était pas
possible d'accord donc vous aviez
d'autres locataires dans cette maison
alors il y oui oui j'ai elle a trouvé
preneur oui cette maison oui oui elle a
trouvé preneur j'ai j'ai trouvé et
aujourd'hui donc mais aujourd'hui vous
vous dormez où aujourd'hui et ben
aujourd'hui c'était les vacances la
semaine dernière c'était les vacances
les enfants étaient partis en vacances
donc j'ai pu j'ai pu profiter des
chambres
mais mais et puis et puis ça tombait
bien parce qu'il
pleuvait parce qu'en fait Véronique elle
a rendu la maison où elle était en étant
sûr que le locataire allait partir
retrouvé sans rien en plus avec votre
moment avec laqu vous vouliez vivre et
si je ne m'abuse il a encore été plus
terrible parce qu'il a fait venir des
services de l'État en disant que c'était
insalubre et que vous deviez faire des
travaux d'urgence il vous a obligé c'est
çaoui le conseil le Conseil
constitutionnel a confirmé cette cette
obligation pour le propriétaire
d'assurer l'entretien de la maison de sa
maison qui est squaté bienvenue dans le
pays de dingue un pays de
fou pay de fou c'est c'est non mais
franchement quand quand on écoute votre
histoire on se dit encore mais je vous
jure c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est quoi non mais je je paye des
fonciers enfin je je paye c'est c'est
c'est euh euh j'ai j'ai travaillé si
j'ai eu un prêt c'est parce que j'ai
travaillé quand on ne travaille pas euh
vous croyez que la banque vousû et et
pourquoi ils veulent pas travailler les
les gens qui qui louent votre maison ils
sont jeunes nous avez dit ils sont en
pleine santé pourquoi ils travaillent
pas ah mais parce qu'ils veulent pas
quoi ils veulent pas il ils veulent pas
bah parce que E moi aussi moi aussi je
veux pas manger des épinardes qui paye
le loyer
madame écoutez ça va être intéressanta
en bonne
partia imigrés papier c'est la CAF donc
c'est aussi des
Français par Laaf vous parlez
Jon
B sur les
imigrés vouz savoir vraiment qui
bénéficie le plus
la et oui faut enlever la nationalité
donc c'est un gratteur vous êtes
certains mais si ce sont des Français pe
importe que ça soit des Français ou des
étrangers il doivent être sanctionnés
comme il le mérite comment on fait doent
être sanctionnés d'être expulsé ils
peuvent pas être expulsés parce que là
c'est la trêvevernale en plus bah ils
peuvent pas être expulsés mais en même
temps en même temps j'ai eu l'assistante
sociale au téléphone qui m'a dit que
qu'il y avait des propositions de
logement donc il y avait des ça qui est
fou ils veulent pas se barrer ben il me
donne pas l'impression de vouloir partir
donc là aujourd'hui vous faites quoi ah
bah aujourd'hui j'attends que quelqu'un
bouge j'attends que
euh euh j'attends j'attends j'attends
peut-être que je vais construire
finalement au fond de mon jardin un
petit un petit bangalo un petit Cabano
en dur ou je sais pas c'est c'est c'est
affligeant c'est affligeant c'est
affligeant oui bien ils ont ça la
trveral c'est le bouclier nucléaire
ouais ces gens-là n'ont pas une HCE
d'humanité quand il vous voit dans votre
jardin quand il voit votre état sé parce
que mais je pense je pense qu'ils ils en
jouit mais s'en fout mais mais quand
j'ai cru comprendre vous étiez atint
d'un cancer c'est quand il voit votre
état de santé ils en on rien à faire ah
non fout ils ont un bon plan ils ont la
cafe il rest là ils bougent
pasè je vous dis il y a plein de
téléspectateurs qui réagissent à 20h31 à
votre histoire et donc aujourd'hui
statuco donc vous vous dites je
construire une petite cabane dans le
jardin et eux pendant qu'ils vont être
dans votre appart en fait ah bah oui
tout à fait mais je croyais qu'il y
avait une loi antiquat non mais ils sont
considérés comme locataire mauvais
payeur il sont inexpulsabl pendant la
trêve évernale sauf s'il y a un
relogement c'est ce que vous
espérezou trouvé un relogement oui mais
ils sont pas obligés de
l'accepter il sont pas obligés de
l'accepter madame les squatter ont plus
de droit que Madame non mais
c'est on leur trouve un logement non non
ça PLA pass on va rester là gà on leur
trouve ce qui est le cas
de non non non non laissez tomber on va
pas le prendre il demand des travaux
dans la maison qui parce que c'est pas
terrible mais sor vous savez que on
raconre la maison est un salubre depuis
justement juin pourquoi elle n'était pas
un salubre avant bien sûr oui puiselle
était un
salise quand il estprise elle était pas
Salum qu'il laisse couler l'eau des
robinets pour faire monter vos factures
en plus oui oui ou oui ah oui mais c'est
mais c'est il faut les triquer il suffit
il suffit que je fasse du bruit des
bruits de vaisselle ou des bruits de de
euh de ben je je travaille le bois en ce
moment j'ai taillé ma haie la haie je
l'ai j'en ai profité pour euh
oui j'ai taillé ma haie oui donc donc
évidemment ça fait du bruit une
tronçonneuse sal Dér Christophe oui donc
euh donc oui il suffit que je fasse il
suffit que je fasse du bruit à 9h le
matin il ils ne vont pas l'accepter ils
vont se manifester ils vont se se
manifester d'une autre façon et la seule
façon pour eux de se manifester c'est
euh bah alors il faut pourrir leur
quotidien quoi
est-ce que G attends parce que j'ai
envie Gill le défenseur des
squatterfend perd ce sont des locataires
mauvais pay on est d'accord sont pas
considérés légalement comme des pouri s
moi je m'en fous
TER pour moi pour moi c'est voilà pour
moi c'est des mecs la loi voil pour moi
c'est des mecs
m'en fous allez vasy fais ta lo vasyf
que la
arrête un peu il faut qu'il dégage
arrête un peu mais c'est pas possible
mais après l'émission quand vous allez
rentrer chez
vous allez constater que la porte été
fracturé qu'il a dit il a dit resterai
tranquillement
dehors il a dit un truc je rappelle il a
dit truc incro mettez-vous un peu dans
la réalité du quotidien de milliers de
Français parce que là c'est c'est c'est
jeunes comme beaucoup tombent sur des
gens sur une personne seule malade et il
sontil les Français sont gentils ce sont
des ce sont des gens patients mais la
patience elle là ses limite un jour ça
finira mal un jour un propriétaire va
prendre des mesures plus plus musclé
plus virile plus coercitive et ça sera
le drame pourtant des cas comme cela il
y en a
il y en a beaucoup on tire la sonnette
d'arme à chaque fois c'est un véritable
scandale et rien ne
bouge fassz pression sur vos suros sur
les sénateurs et les autres
parlementaires pour que on arrête
de c'est à cause de la loi c'est à cause
de la loi qui est
injuste plî juste mon un petit truc pour
pour pour vous parce que on a fait un
sondage sur Karim benzem aussi
oui à
60,4% ils sont d'accord avec Stan
répond on
pas est-ce que je peux dire quelqu chose
pendant 30 secondes à Monsieur ravier
bien s il est là avec tout mon respect
vous êtes sénateur les planquets de la
République les sénateurs c'est
incroyable vous dépensez l'argent de la
nation vous devriez avoir hte monsieur
Rav vous avez la sécurité sociale gare
pour toute votre vie des retraites de
planqué vous êtes un planqué de la
République et vous allez sur des g soyez
dig monur Rav c'est tout ce que j'ai à
vous dire soyz les sénateurs c'est les
pires planqués de la République c'est
vrai ou pas je me plains pas voilà plz
pasuxar je B en tout il a
beaucoupoup s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît beaucoup de réactions je vous le
dis et il y a 60 % des gens qui sont
d'accord avec Stéphane Ravier je vous
dis le sondage c'est incroyable mais
voilà 60 % des gens il y a beaucoup de
gens qui m'écrivent et qui qui voilà
rag non on sait que c'est pas possible
non mais on sait que c'est pas possible
c'est comme ton truc des squats on sait
très bien qu'on peut pas les fout dehors
bah voilà mais si on était dans ta
France ser la France en fait tu veux que
je te dise le problème c'est qu'on est
dans ta France voilà on est dans ta
France je parle pas de Benzema je parle
sur les squatter va dans le mur il
accélère exactement mais lui lui non
mais la France de G c'est la France par
parce qu'il est pas dans le
véhicule boucer le
bouclier ur êes pour êes pour vivre
ensemble vous êtes pour le vivre
ensemble mais vous nêtes pas pour le
vivre avec vous le pratiquez pas vivre
avec le pratique vivre avec
les on pas Benz
on le Bou c'est pour protéger les gens
le
bouclier c'est pour empêcher les gens
pour pas qu'on les mette dehors résultat
c'est la propriétaire qui est
dehors lui qui fait les
[Musique]
loisi merci rien fait moi Véronique
Véronique on va suivre votre affaire on
va essayer de vous aider quand même on
va essayer de vous aider Véronique voir
si on peut vous aider un peu parce que
vous êtes vous êtes vraiment je vous dis
on on a tous on a tous craqué pour vous
on vous c'est vrai ah oui merci on va
parler de ce policier qui sort son arme
et tir en l'air après avoir été
violemment pris à parti dans l'un cité
marseillaise et Gil verdz nous dira
pourquoi il aurait dû lever plutôt son
doigt euh voilà merci à tout suite à
tout de suite
merci